i would like to begin with a little
experiment
in a moment i'm going to ask if you
would close your eyes and see if you can
work out
what emotions you're feeling right now
now you're not going to tell anyone or
anything the idea is to see how easy or
perhaps
hard you find it to pinpoint exactly
what you're feeling
and i um i thought i'd give you 10
seconds to do this
okay right let's start
okay that's it time's up how did it go
you're probably feeling a little bit
under pressure
maybe suspicious of the person next to
you did they definitely have their eyes
closed
perhaps you felt some strange distant
worry about that email you sent this
morning or
excitement about something you've got
planned for this evening
maybe you felt that exhilaration that
comes when we get together in big groups
of people like this
the welsh call it well from the word for
boat sails or maybe you felt
all of these things there are some
emotions which wash the world in a
single color
like the terror felt as a car skids
but more often our emotions crowd and
jostle together until it is
actually quite hard to tell them apart
some slide past so quickly you'd hardly
even
notice them like the nostalgia that will
make you
reach out to grab a familiar brand in
the supermarket
and then there are others that we hurry
away from fearing that they'll burst on
us
like the jealousy that causes you to
search a loved one's pockets
and of course there are some emotions
which are so peculiar you might not even
know what to call them
perhaps sitting there you had a little
tingle of a desire for an emotion
one eminent french sociologist called
ilynx
the delirium that comes with minor acts
of chaos
so for example if you stood up right now
and emptied the contents of your bag all
over the floor
perhaps you experienced one of those odd
untranslatable emotions for which
there's no obvious english equivalent
you might have felt the feeling the
dutch cool gazella hates
being cozy and warm inside with friends
when it's cold and damp outside
maybe if you were really lucky you felt
this
bassorexia a sudden urge to kiss someone
we live in an age where knowledge of
emotions is an extremely
important commodity where emotions are
used to explain
many things exploited by our politicians
manipulated by algorithms emotional
intelligence which is the skill of being
able to recognize and name your own
emotions
and those of other people is considered
so important that this is taught in our
schools and businesses
and encouraged by our health services
but despite all of this i sometimes
wonder if the way we think about
emotions
is becoming impoverished sometimes we're
not even that clear what an emotion
even is you've probably
heard the theory that our entire
emotional life can be boiled down to a
handful
of basic emotions this idea is actually
about 2
000 years old but in our own time some
evolutionary
psychologists have suggested that these
six emotions happiness sadness
fear disgust anger surprise
are expressed by everyone across the
globe in exactly the same way
and therefore represent the the building
blocks of our
entire emotional lives well if you look
at an emotion like this
then it looks like a simple reflex it's
triggered by an external predicament
it's hardwired it's there to protect us
from harm
so you see a bear your heart rate
quickens your pupils dilate
you feel frightened you run very very
fast
the problem with this picture is it's
not entirely doesn't entirely capture
what an emotion is of course the
physiology is extremely important
but it's not the only reason why we feel
the way we do
at any given moment
what if i was to tell you that in the
12th century
some troubadours didn't see yawning
as caused by tiredness or boredom like
we do today
but thought it a symbol of the deepest
love
or that in that same period brave men
knights commonly fainted out of
dismay what if i was to tell you that
some
early christians who lived in the desert
believed that
flying demons who mainly came out at
lunchtime could infect them with an
emotion they called
acidity or acidia a kind of lethargy
that was sometimes so intense it could
even kill them
or that boredom as we know and love it
today
was first really only felt by the
victorians in response to new ideas
about
leisure time and self-improvement
what if we were to think again about
those odd untranslatable words for
emotions and wonder
whether some cultures might feel an
emotion more intensely
just because they've bothered to name
and talk about it
like the russian tusca a feeling of
maddening dissatisfaction
said to blow in from the great plains
the most recent developments in
cognitive science
show that emotions are not simple
reflexes
but immensely complex elastic systems
that respond both to the biologies that
we've inherited
and to the cultures that we live in now
they are
cognitive phenomena they're shaped not
just by our bodies
but by our thoughts our concepts our
language
the neuroscientist lisa feldman barrett
has become
very interested in this dynamic
relationship between words
and emotions she argues that when we
learn
a new word for an emotion new feelings
are sure to follow as a historian i've
long suspected that as language changes
our emotions do too when we look to the
past it's easy to see that emotions have
changed
sometimes very dramatically in response
to new cultural expectations and
religious beliefs
new ideas about gender ethnicity and age
even in response to new political and
economic ideologies there is a
historicity
to emotions that we are only recently
starting to understand
so i agree absolutely that it does us
good to learn new words for emotions
but i think we need to go further i
think to be truly emotionally
intelligent
we need to understand where those words
have come from
and what ideas about how we ought to
live and behave
they are smuggling along with them
let me tell you a story it begins in a
garrett
in the late 17th century in the swiss
university town of basel
inside there's a dedicated student
living some 60 miles
away from home he stops turning up to
his lectures
and his friends come to visit and they
find him dejected and
feverish having heart palpitations
strange sores breaking out on his body
doctors are called and they think it's
so serious that prayers are said for him
in the local church and it's only really
when they're preparing
to return this young man home so that he
can die
that they realize what's going on
because once they lift him onto the
stretcher
his breathing becomes less labored and
by the time he's got to the gates of his
hometown
he's almost entirely recovered and
that's when they realize that he's been
suffering from a very powerful form
of homesickness it's so powerful that it
might have killed him
well in 1688 a young doctor johannes
hoffa
heard of this case and others like it
and christened the illness
nostalgia the diagnosis quickly caught
on in medical circles around europe
the english actually thought they were
probably immune because of all the
travel that they did in the empire and
so on but
but soon there were cases cropping up in
britain too the last person to die from
nostalgia
was an american soldier fighting during
the first world war
in france how is it possible
that you could die from nostalgia less
than a hundred years ago
but today not only does the word mean
something different a sickening for
a lost time rather than a lost place but
homesickness itself is seen as less
serious
sort of downgraded from something you
could die from to something you may be
worried your kid might be suffering from
it's a sleepover
this change seems to have happened in
the early 20th century
but why was it the invention of
telephones or the expansion of the
railways
was it perhaps the coming of modernity
with its celebration of restlessness and
travel and progress that made sickening
for the familiar
seem rather unambitious you
and i inherit that massive
transformation in values
and it's one reason why we might not
feel homesickness today
as acutely as we used to
it's important to understand that these
large historical changes
influence our emotions partly because
they affect how we feel
about how we feel today we celebrate
happiness happiness is uh
supposed to make us better workers and
parents and partners it's supposed to
make us live longer
in the 16th century sadness was thought
to do most of those things
it's even possible to read self-help
books from that period which try to
encourage
sadness in readers by giving them lists
of reasons to be disappointed
these self-help authors thought you
could cultivate sadness as a skill
since being expert in it would make you
more resilient when something bad did
happen to you
as invariably it would i think we could
learn from this today
feel sad today and you might feel
impatient
even a little ashamed feel sad in the
16th century and you
might feel a little bit smug
of course our emotions don't just change
across time
they also change from place to place the
baning people of papua new guinea speak
of a wombok
a feeling of lethargy that descends when
a house guest finally leaves
now you or i might feel relief but
in in culture departing guests are
thought to shed a sort of heaviness so
they can travel more easily
and this heaviness infects the air and
causes this alum book
and so what they do is leave a bowl of
water out overnight to absorb this air
and then very early the next morning
they
they wake up and have a ceremony and
throw the water away
so here's a good example of spiritual
practices and geographical realities
combining
to bring a distinct emotion into life
and make it disappear again
one of my favorite emotions is a
japanese word
am i am i is a very common word in japan
but it is actually quite hard to
translate
it means something like the the pleasure
that you get when you're able to
temporarily
hand over responsibility for your life
to someone else
now anthropologists suggest that one
reason why this word might have been
named and
and celebrated in japan is because of
that country's traditionally
collectivist culture whereas the feeling
of
dependency may be more fraught amongst
english speakers
who have learned to value
self-sufficiency
and individualism this might be
a little simplistic but it is
tantalizing
what might our emotional languages tell
us not just about
what we feel but about what we value
most
most people who tell us to pay attention
to our well-being
talk of the importance of naming our
emotions
but these names aren't neutral labels
they are freighted with our culture's
values and expectations and they
transmit ideas about who we think we are
learning new and unusual words for
emotions will help attune us to the more
finely grained aspects of our inner
lives
but more than this i think these words
are worth
caring about because they remind us how
powerful the connection is
between what we think and how we end up
feeling
true emotional intelligence requires
that we understand the
social uh the political the
cultural forces that have shaped what
we've come to believe about our emotions
and understand how happiness or hatred
or
love or anger might still be changing
now because if we want to measure our
emotions
and teach them in our schools and listen
as our politicians tell us how important
they are
then it is a good idea that we
understand where the assumptions we have
about them have come from
and whether they still truly speak to us
now
i want to end with an emotion i often
feel when i'm working as a historian
it's a french word depismol it evokes
the
giddy disorientation that you feel in an
unfamiliar place
one of my favorite parts of being a
historian is when something i've
completely taken for granted some very
familiar part of my life is suddenly
made strange again
depismore is unsettling but it's
exciting too
and i hope you might be having just a
little glimpse of it right now
thank you
[Music]
you